[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه تعلن انتهاء عمليه البحث والانقاذ
في معظم المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال وتقول
ان عدد القتلى قارب اربعين الفا و700 وفي
سوريا قفلت مساعدات احداهما امميه تدخلان
الى شمال غرب سوريا للاسهام في عمليه
الاغاثه دمشق تقول ان قصفا اسرائيليا على
كفر سوسه بضواحي العاصمه اوقع قتلى وجرحى
وتطالب بتحرك دوري لوقف الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه الاذاعه الاسرائيليه ترجح
استهدافه شخصيه كبيره في الهجوم طهران
تنفي سقوط ضحايا ايرانيين ونتنياهو يؤكد
عدم السماح لايران بالتمركز على حدود
اسرائيل الشماليه
بعد طرد السلطات التونسيه لامينه الاتحاد
النقابي الاوروبي الامين العام للاتحاد
التونسي للشغل يؤكدون الاتحاد لن يقف
محيدا دون دفاع عن الحريات النقابيه
والفرديه والعامه ويقول ان البلاد لا يمكن
ان تبنى بخطاب الكراهيه
تلبيه لدعوه القوى الوطنيه والاسلاميه
والحراك الشبابي اضراب شامل يسود بلدات
وضواحي القدس المحتله احتجاجا على اجراءات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي القمعيه بحق سكانها
حيث اغلق السكان محالهم تجاريه بالاضافه
للمداخل الرئيسيه لبعض البلدات واشعل
النيران في اطارات السيارات الى اللقاء